[Music]
this week on
forward people think running for
president on the outside looking in
especially if you don't pay attention
they think it's like an ego exercise
it's an ego Crusher it's an ego demol it
is so grueling and so painful and so
expensive from a Time Talent treasure
standpoint not just money people are
burnt out jaded so it's hard to shake
them and be like yo we really can do
better than this but I hope Taylor finds
love if Taylor gets married and has
babies it will be one of the best baby
booms in this country that's probably my
last prediction yeah whatever she names
the baby will be the most popular baby
name that
[Music]
year welcome everyone to
2024 the year that we've all heard so
much about is here uh and to bring us in
right we have our old friend for
predictions episode campaign manager for
Dean Phillips Zach growman is here yay
is that my claim to fame now man I mean
[__] you were my campaign manager and uh
so you you know that you could actually
do a more authoritative Yang uh Dean
comparison we could do one of those side
by-side
charts after your campaign I was like
I'm never touching politics again I'm
pretty have come on this show and said
I'm never touching politics again Andrew
and back
baby wrote me back in he's a good guy
he's a real deal we're so order of
operations we're going to review how we
did in 2023 that'll be good fun and then
we'll start predicting for 2024 but I
I'm pumped you're working with Dean uh I
think that Joe Biden is an historically
weak candidate I think that he will lose
to Trump in the general um and the
Democratic party owes us at a minimum a
real competitive process but what they
actually owe us is the best possible
candidate to defeat Trump and Joe Biden
ain't it I mean like that that like
that's just you know empirical so thank
you Dean and thank you Zach for making
this stuff happen New Hampshire votes
January 23d um and we can go into the
predictions but first how did we do in
2023 so 2023 was fun that's why I
listened to you last night just to recap
um so a couple things off the front and
one I owe you a Boba T because um I had
the over on 15 Republicans running and I
think that final number floated around
probably exactly what you said which was
12 um nice uh confirm but it certainly
wasn't 15 so I owe you Boba te and
actually what it should be is Boba te
ice cream which they have in the New
Hudson yards Jing Fu Tong it's a
Taiwanese joint and it's delicious B I
like Boba ice cream I love it's
incredible soft serve check it out it's
ridiculous it's like all the joy of boba
but in ice cream it's wonderful so a
couple things I I'll recap our
predictions I will say this though
Andrew there were a couple where we
really nailed and I think you should
have we should have more listeners on
this podcast because it was preing it
was uh there were a couple things we
really got spot on and a couple things
big swing and a miss but a couple the
stuff that I think that was more our
lane we really did nail um so you
predicted here were your predictions you
predicted a mild recession uh depends
how you Define recession um I what what
I I'd say and this we can talk about in
this episode so I think that 2023
prediction just gets punted to
2024 is I feeling and so you know like
for for 2023 you'd say it it's a Miss um
but you know like it could be something
of a uh to soon call yeah I don't some
of these things are tough because you
look at recession from a technical
definition no but if you look at are
people feeling better or worse about the
economy on both sides of the aisle yes
there would be a lot of people that
would say right right now we're in a
recession based upon their own lives by
the stats I think the stats I saw that
uh 72 75 even 79% of Americans don't
think the econom is going well yeah it's
not great um and this is honestly what
you ran on in 2020 on
the what we're measuring GDP stock
market growth true these things are not
really reflective in most of the country
um they're they're good for for us
frankly for folks that are um college
educated and and um thriving in the
economy in various ways and I say that
humbly but they're not good for the
average the average person and even the
above average person it's really tough
um I see it a lot so well I call that a
milk uh like lukewarm if you will yeah
yeah I mean if you're generous lukewarm
I'll take it yeah uh the second one was
where you nailed where you said Biden
will announce re-election you said in Q2
I didn't confirm that but I think it
might have been Q2 or late q1 nailed
that um the big one you nailed was the
rise of uh the dissatisfied middle um
Independence in a third party sort of
thing and I think RFK is
the big emblem for that one yeah yeah
you nailed that one because he didn't
really exist as a national figure when
we were talking about so nailed that
Zack launched a company also true you
had a new book also true so um that's
good fun those are good um and then my
predictions were um the one I did nail
was I predicted a a heated up war
between mainstream media and Independent
Media with Elon Musk fueling it and I
think I nailed that one um full credit
on that man yeah um well that's I can
brag on that one because I swung in a
miss and the other two I had D San's
runs which I got right but I had that he
wins a republican nomination and that's
almost certainly not going to happen um
I my caveats were right I did say look
he's kind of a nerd and that the he's
never been vetted on a presidential
level so that's the risk which I didn't
understand the risk I just thought he
would have been a more vibrant Trump and
the reality is that's not the case Trump
is still Trump and he's not even close
yeah you you missed that he's uh shrimpy
unlikable and can't simulate human
interaction
yeah yeah you did you had we had said
nerdy you talked about him being Harvard
Law like the reality is like he's just
retail politics still matter um which is
a good thing for democracy what's
interesting Zach I me you know I mean
you saw him speaking in the the most
favorable context which was he was
speaking to a favorable audience yeah
good point uh yeah so you know you you
had a a data point that um would give a
certain saw him on a panel which is
usually a somewhat it's like a 30 to 40%
of what a real debate is is it's the
other 60% is the hard part to be fair
but you have to be have some sort of
floor to do that well and he had it um
but man you're right it was a big bust
got that wrong and the other one was
that I thought there'd be a web 3
mainstream company um where it was I
basically had moms and and other folks
using web 3 without knowing it and that
hasn't happened yet uh my bias from
being married to Karly Riley probably
clouded that judgment I still think that
call is right but it's not now I'm too
early well yeah sometimes you get the
time frame wrong I I'm very bullish on
that web 3 I'm still like I'm buying eth
all the time I'm very very very bullish
but I don't have an answer um I don't
have timing so anyway one for three I'll
take it man I'll take it and I think we
also had a couple um things on the
election preview that that's why I meant
where we were really pression where you
had said you weren't even predicting you
were just like this is what's going to
happen was Joe Biden announces and the
Dems establishment Dems fall in line and
you predicted the ri Ripple effects of
that and we're seeing it now and it's
very very challenging and very very
frustrating um but you nailed that and
that's why I'm like look we need more
listeners and like GE like our listeners
are growing for the record and you guys
we're grateful to you but that call was
spot on and you've made it on CNN Etc
but well done man we're living that yeah
so I I guess that we can lead off with
our politics discussion so conventional
wisdom right now is it's going to be a
trump Biden rematch in
2024 uh I think right now if you looked
at it you would say um that's still the
more than 50% likely matchup um but
people ask me all the time it's like hey
what do you think the odds are of
something like Dean Phillips upsetting
Joe well let's look at the Republican
primary first because it's a little
easier so you know voting is going to
start in two weeks in Iowa I think Trump
generally speaking rolls through uh the
Republican nomination it's breaking in
his favor uh there are a couple of
things that could happen that would make
his path more difficult but right now
it's Trump Trump trump uh and uh it
could be over pretty quick honestly
because um Dan santis uh is staking it
all in Iowa so if Iowa doesn't go his
way he's probably out and then um New
Hampshire will be the end of Chris
Christie um almost certainly and and I
uh and then South Carolina will be Nikki
Haley's um either Last Stand or Victory
party and but that's pretty quick like
it's going to be a fast calendar the
question is
does the only way I see him not rolling
is if um the Dems or they they do what
the Dems did essentially in 20120 where
the um let's call it the
anti- progressive the anti- Bernie Lane
lines up behind a candidate which they
all you know Pete Amy K whoever was left
lined up behind Joe right um and if the
Republicans do the same thing where you
have Christie and DeSantis and VI drop
out and they all line up behind Haley
maybe but I don't know if that's that's
not a clean tradeoff like if you like
Des santis you might be a good chunk of
them are probably still yeah so so nck
Nikki H is the most viable anti-trump
Contender she's got momentum she's got
money the best case scenario for her is
that Chris Christie Dr out immediately
uh the last poll has Nikki Haley at 29%
in New Hampshire Trump at 44 and Chris
Christie at 10 and I'm gonna suggest
that virtually none of that Chris
Christie 10 would go to Trump because if
you're a Christie fan you're not a trump
fan so let's say Nikki Haley gets the
majority of that then and then you get
some love from Independence uh and the
rest of it it's conceivable that Nikki
Haley pulls off an upset in New
Hampshire goes into South Carolina with
momentum it's our home state
she wins and then the entire thing
becomes a long protracted Affair the
best thing that can happen for Nikki
haly is that Chris Christie drops out
before New Hampshire endorses her uh and
then she upsets him in New Hampshire so
for people who are trying to keep an eye
on what's Happening that that's the key
state in my opinion New Hampshire if
Trump wins both Iowa and New Hampshire
then he's GNA go into South Carolina and
and it'd be very hard for Nikki to win
there though if Nikki uh wins in South
Carolina the thing can go on for for
more and more States the major variable
in this is New Hampshire and the
variable there is whether Christie drops
out something happened just yesterday
that's very very bad I'll say this and
you know that Chris Christie got 10% in
this New Hampshire poll and thus
qualified for the the CNN debate um if
if Chris Christie had missed that debate
then the odds of him dropping out would
be higher yeah so it sounds like the
Republican going to keep this
interesting for
us
interesting well for for for you know
for like a a in my opinion this thing
could be a wrap uh by Yeah by by by by
February how are you going to get
healthier this year one way to do so is
have healthy chef-crafted meals
delivered to your door stressfree what
the heck am I talking about Factor
Factor's 2-minute meals are your secret
weapon to a healthier happier you I've
been eating Factor for this last number
of weeks and wow it's been a game
changer we're talking about delicious
chicken taco bowl spicy pablano beef and
every time I'm like ooh this is going to
be tasty and it is makes you feel good
it's cost efficient it's flexible no
prep no mess you can't screw it up just
poke a couple holes in it heat it up and
it's fresh never Frozen I got to say if
you try Factor you are going to be
pumped it's going to make you healthier
happier more productive in the New Year
head to factor meals.com
y50 and use code Yang 50 to get 50% off
that's code y50 at factor meals.com
sl50 to get 50% off
Factor so on the other side of the coin
you are making it so that it's not just
the the Biden coronation and the Biden
coronation strikes me as total Madness
honestly uh like you know I mean the
dude's at 37% approval Monmouth just had
him at 34% in a poll I I I just saw come
out Joe Biden even said at a press
conference 50 Democrats could beat Trump
which begs the question it's like why
not let one of them
run yeah because if you have a generic
Democrat he or she beats Trump by eight
whereas you lose to him by three or four
so that's like an 11 12 point swing
that's pretty much the ball game so um
I'm going be more kg than I normally am
on on talking about the the demam race
um and I was telling Andrew before the
show is that I have a I try not to be a
hypocrite most thing but I've told my
team on Dean Phillips campaign I'm like
look no one talks to press unless you go
through myself or the com shop um and
here I am talking to quote press on a
podcast I don't I don't am I the Press
but but I say to them like the Press is
the Press is not your friend um and
they're not and there um it's because
their job to be a friend um but that
said Andrew you objectively are a friend
so it's a little different here's the
big piece of this is so and we talked
about this honestly last year we did
these predictions in that in 20 the
Republican race in 2020 they just
canceled the debates essentially and no
one cared and the the only people that
did care was the Democrats being like
tis tisk not good for democracy but not
many people really cared um and now the
Dems are doing the same thing well
there's no debates and no no primary and
which if you have a dominant incumbent I
at least see the logic where it's like
what's the point right um but you don't
have a dominant incumbent right now and
um so that's where it feels
anti-democratic and you're seeing that
across the country in various states
where they're just lining up and they're
like Florida does not have a Democratic
primary if you live in Florida you don't
get to vote um if for if you're a
Democrat you don't get vote um so that
to me is dark I think it's really dark
not to have debates I think even before
Dean Phillips Maran Williamson was in
double digits in certain States that's a
that's a legit um version of a
Challenger given given uh approval
numbers Etc State of Affairs so that's
really frustrating I think my bold
prediction is that Joe Biden's not the
nominee this time around um I think
that's that's my bold prediction whether
I'm not going to talk whether it's my
guy and I have a lot of reasons to think
it's my guy or it's it's someone else or
or something I think but I think
competition is going to sneak its its
way in here I will join you in this Zach
um I I I think I think there'll be
another nominee on the Democratic ticket
too yeah we're biased of course yeah
we're self-interested um in the sense
that come on man like what are we're
gonna Sleepwalk we're gonna walk right
in yeah in the sense that like I I think
that the country deserves a nominee who
could beat Trump uh I really like Dean
Phillips uh and uh donated to him and am
supporting him in various ways but
here's the thing that no one's talking
about that I'd love to help make this
case you know one reason why Joe's
numbers are going down is that he's
running again and we can tell it's the
wrong decision and people are pissed you
know like that the thing that Joe had
going for him is that he's like a good
dude that loves the country and in this
case loving the country means getting
out of the way and letting someone else
run uh you know like do you love your
your job as president and the fact
everyone has to listen to you or do you
love the country and he's failing this
test and Americans are picking up on
that now the Press isn't touching that
narrative but I'm with you bold
prediction number one shared by Andrew
and Zach uh the Democratic party has a
nominee that is not uh Joe Biden I hear
this a lot that a primary would hurt Joe
um or help Trump and I think that's
insane I think that's an insane
statement
ignoring our own bias I'm trying to be
objective with that I think that's you
know mo primaries um end up with the
strongest candidate after um almost
100% of the time there's some exceptions
but most of the time you do the other
thing is you can love Ruth Bader
Ginsburg and think she's been wonderful
for this country and a Powerhouse and a
role model Etc and also say at the same
time on the other hand that she should
have retired earlier so Barack Obama
could have named her replacement and she
didn't do that and it hurt women that's
these are fundamentally choose
statements and so well I mean o
overstaying your welcome is a disease in
American politics you know like people
do it way too much yeah one thing I
appreciate about folks you know who who
still had some time in the clock and
were like yeah I'm out you know it's
like oh good you know and by the way you
know who's very high on that list for me
is Dean Phillips because like guy's not
running for congress again um and if he
just hung out in Congress I mean the
those guys have essentially lifetime
appointments yeah you need to admire
with the the I think and and we' talked
about this before a lot is that people
think running for president on the
outside looking especially if you don't
pay attention they think it's like an
ego exercise and it's it's an ego
Crusher it's an ego demol it is so
grueling and so painful and so expensive
from a Time Talent treasure standpoint
not just money one of the hardest things
ever do um and certainly the hardest
thing the two hardest things I've ever
done are are running with you and now
running running with Dean um it's really
really hard that's not to be like w w
that's you know that's a gig and that
what's the what's the light at the end
of the tunnel is you get to rule the
Free World right but I do like that
about our democracy like you got to be
ready for prime time you got to be a
certain level of a Trailblazer and
Soldier to do it um even if you have the
easiest path ever if you're Hillary
Clinton and the the Stars line up for
you right you have the whole party
behind you it's still hard political
prediction number two I think third
party candidates break 10% in uh in
November um you know you've got RFK you
nationally or or in certain States um
nationally composite so you've got RFK
you've got Corel West you've got Jill
Stein and then there's the elephant in
the non room is like does someone like
Mansion run and no labels I mean no
labels has bought this ballot access are
they going to use it um but I think that
the discontent um with now this could
change if we're right and you you swap
out Joe for Dean Phillips or
somethingone like that um but uh at this
point I I think you wind up with
generational high in third party voting
um in in November mhm the real question
is is who it pulls from and I think um
there's progressives and populists that
if they're running Joe Biden it's
they're really going to go to an
independent um or to Trump and then if
there's a strong Democratic candidate I
think an RFK or type actually pulls from
Trump I mean I mean whoever the moderate
would is the generic Democrat would pull
from Trump as well so that's what's so
frustrating and I think this whole thing
is
um we have a general sense of what right
looks like here like the populist
platform in America where it's
affordable health care affordable
education affordable housing um like a
little bit of a bigger government for
this 21st century and not crazy not
insane just a little bigger like a
little bit of raising the floor um a
little bit of capitalism with the floor
I mean hell in some cases you don't have
to spend money you'd save money I mean
look at the Healthcare System healthare
man I've now I've now done a lot of
research on this the business case for
Medicare for all is um ridiculously
strong ridiculously strong um and you
made it a good amount in 2020 so yeah um
totally in in so many ways I mean the
dean Phillips campaign uh is a
continuation of a lot of the things uh
that we ran on it's super fun like
people don't realize it but he's for
Medicare for all uh he's for trying to
make things affordable on every level
he's for like you know like the new the
measurements that like American
scorecard type stuff Andrew talking
about measure the I mean he's he's more
of a like a populous moderate it's it's
he's where most of the country is um no
one and now like my job is to get people
to know him um and that's hard if
there's no one of the things we had in
2020 Andrew we had an apparatus we had
debates we had Co bear having the
candidates on we had the Washington Post
New York Times all these places do like
candidate features like there was an
apparatus come on man Dean philps was on
the Andrew Yang podcast done and done
I'm kidding but
uh our aome producer Daniel you can add
a sound effect yes but it um but to your
point it's a different process um we
urge everyone listening most of you have
already done this but do go to de24
docomo do it for my guy Zach Zach is
still a newlywed look at him building a
life investing in a presidential
candidate named Dean Phillips go check
out Dean 24.com do it for Zack do it for
our guy Zack thanks guys I do it for the
country do it for yourself do it for
your family my brother's been joking
that this campaign will help me write
the sequel to my book longer than long
shot um long shot too long longest
shot hey YouTube thanks for watching
please do hit like And subscribe and hit
that Bell if you want to be notified
every time a new episode drops probably
on Mondays but hit that Bell and thank
you next up we have uh the economy then
we're going to close with tech so the
economy I mentioned this uh I think that
the mild recession i' predicted for 23
happens in 24 which is by the way
another reason I think having Joe Biden
U as a nominee is a disaster Biden omic
doesn't hit
now like it's not gonna all of a sudden
everyone's gonna be like oh shoot like
Biden I'm I mean that was malpractice
just naming the economy after Biden that
was dumb from day one um it it's worse
when people aren't loving it there are
just massive imbalances in the economy
that are going to come to roost I mean
the obvious ones are commercial real
estate and urban centers I mean that
stuff needs to get reval valued uh
that's going to end up hitting the
balance sheets of various local banks
residential real estate in my opinion is
right there too uh that there's a a ton
of paralysis in the market where there
are a bunch of folks being like hey I
can't sell because uh I don't want to
lower the price and people like well I
can't buy at the price because I can't
get a mortgage um people just got very
used to mortgage rates that were sub 4%
now mortgage rates are starting to come
back down below 8% but that still ends
up in your monthly payment uh there are
so many young people I know who are like
not even looking anymore so um I I think
that uh you're going to to see a
retrenchment in some places even in
terms of residential something that
people don't recognize as much too is uh
there's a a problem in terms of startup
valuations where startups raised money
in 20 20 and 2021 at valuations that
don't make much much sense um I advise a
company that just cut its valuation by
50% um to get some new money in and
they're one of the lucky ones and that
they actually got some money got money
yeah yeah there are a bunch of startups
that are not getting money uh I I know a
bunch of people in Tech um who have get
been laid off recently and these were
people I would never have given any
thought to like folks that are like very
competent and accomplished uh and in
their forward
and then you know I just randomly hear
it's like hey like I'm I'm now at Loose
Ends uh you know I was working at this
big tech tech company um so you know
most people and this is one of the
things I said is like look commercial
real estate uh and and Entrepreneurship
aren't normal jobs aren't Norm I mean
they have effects in various ways
commercial real estate will certainly
have a big effect like when it gets
revalued um residential affects a lot
more people um but I think that there
are still imbalances and shoes to drop
uh and when they do uh you know there
there are going to be some economic
repercussions that don't help people
even who aren't touching those
Industries so I I think the mild
recession does come in 24 so a couple
numbers that are crazy the biggest one
to me is credit card debt it's
outrageous a lot of people don't know
their interest rates on credit cards
there's some numbers on that but um they
they're like 27 30% that you know
they'll they'll kill you well I you know
you could throw the the reinitiation of
student loan payment into the mix um I I
saw a stat that said 40% of people
didn't pay in October and that might
have been confusion but some of it is
probably can't afford to this is like
the time of year every four years we get
to try and reset the direction of the
country and we don't really get to do it
right now and that's frustrating I would
say this if the economy is so good why
is my rent so damn High you know what I
mean and like I that's I'm I'm a dink
I'm a dual income no kids if it's tight
for me come on you know like it's it
can't be great in the rest of the
country and I know that because you know
spoken with people all the country so
it's that's it's we have housing
education Healthcare driving everybody
nuts and if those don't get fixed no
one's going to feel the econom is good
doesn't matter how good the stock market
is it doesn't matter about Venture
valuations like those things are are the
Canary and the coal mine in some ways
they warning signs but that's what I'm
saying is they're the warning signs
they're they're the growth curve and
then if you smush the growth
curve eventually you start getting to
the the the um Main Street uh mom and
pop you know average consumer but you're
right I've seen stats on uh delinquency
and various things like Auto
delinquencies yeah credit card debt
going up like there are a bunch of
things that suggest that consumers are
weakening uh the student loan like
non-payment rate or confusion rate or
whatever you know you add it all up and
like to me that like that this stuff
rolls over into a recession sometime in
the next 12 months my prediction is I
think we're going to see the combination
of people staying at home a lot more and
Pops of civil unrest um and protests I
don't know if they particularly turn
violent but pops of anger and so what I
mean by that is um I'm seeing this in
New Hampshire with political events and
I'm not even talking about ours I'm
talking about the Republican Party um
where you just have student in these
college events of VI and Christie and
Haley doing College events and there
there's no students there there's just
NADA my my brother's been evaluating a
company in um in his world and he's one
of the things they been there's a lot of
crazy data on the younger
Generations because Netflix and Hulu and
entertainment and video games are so
powerful and so entertaining people are
staying home a lot more and then to get
them off their ass it needs to be
like Tik Tock instagramable in the sense
it has to be this like life altering
experience that they sharable experience
and so brands are paying crazy money to
be at these kind of festivals and
concerts and experiences because the
brand experience is really nice like
event marketing is somewhat uh making it
a weird comeback um so that's why I
think this plays out outside of like
various versions of the economy where
people are at home most of the time and
I think hate anger tainment if you
will bubbles them up and then as issues
occur whether it's Israel Gaza whether
it's the economy whether it's another
George Floyd type tragedy you see
various pops of anger that are
shortlived because they're going to go
right back home um but I think we're
going to see more and more of this and
you predicted this in your book uh war
on normal people but um I I think you
predicted more like consistent violence
and anger and we saw that around George
Floyd but now I think you're going to
see like at home lazy to Pops of anger
back to at home lazy I could be wrong
but that's my sense you should qu a term
for that man some call slacktivism but
it's like uh the lazy protest it's like
show up show up ones for the Graham then
I'm back to Netflix I don't know yeah
it's it's interesting too how uh now the
actors are back from their strike but
the the media companies holy cow I don't
know if people have been noticing the
turmoil I mean even if you say something
like Disney's
lost money uh and you think like I
thought Disney was this Juggernaut I
mean like Disney is having major major
challenges most of the major media
companies are having big challenges uh
it's because streaming is a freaking
terrible business uh you know like the
only one that's made at work is Netflix
everyone else is just losing money
because the subscribers are fickle and
then content expensive to make is that
the the challenge yeah and and people
will not sign up for more than a certain
number of streamers you know like after
you you get to two we looked at this
Andrew where was like um the V like a
lot of these um how these are funded
somewhat if it's a public company and
you can get a really good multiple on
your subscribers like that's where it
gets good right so if you have a million
people paying 10 bucks a month you can
make that a bill you can ramp that
multiple up to be a billion dollar
company and then you have equity and and
you can get cash to to create great
content that has to keep going but
valuations are down it's not really
enough uh the model gets worse if you
will uh and you have to forward look it
takes years to make a good movie or TV
show Etc right well the tough part is
we're really being conditioned man you
know like we're we're being conditioned
and you're seeing it with the failure of
some movies in the box office like to
get me to the box office uh it's got to
be like barbin Heimer or something you
know it's Simmons made that prediction a
while back by the way he said uh he said
the only reason to go to the movies I
Bill Simmons like the the ringer he's a
sports guy but he does a lot of pop
culture and he said something
interesting he said the only reason to
go to box office is like your Marvel's
where it's like the big and that's you
know Marvel's been struggling but
theoretically the like Mega it and then
he said culturally relevant movies and
when he said this is when the social
network came out it's like everybody
wanted had to see that and I think
that's still the case um and it's ruined
like think about how many good movies
let's call it the '90s that were just
like shitty 90minut like lowbudget stuff
that are wonderful right like How to
Lose a Guy in 10 Days I love that movie
it's a good romcom I don't think that
gets made today I you know I I I was a
very very loyal theater goer I even had
the AMC stubs card and the whole thing I
get like free popcorn but yeah it's a
harsher media environment it's one
reason why I'm I'm actually grateful to
everyone who who tunes into the podcast
I was I just I was just at uh like an
industry event and apparently podcast of
uh gotten shelled right and left and I
was like oh shoot like we're actually
doing fine we're like growing like you
know so thank you yeah well same it's
it's similar to the subscription thing
there's only so many pods you can listen
to right yeah totally and so really
grateful to people who think that this
is worth it um thank
you this podcast is sponsored by
expressvpn when you go to the bathroom
you always close the door behind you
because you don't want random people
seeing what you're doing but when you go
online people sometimes can see what
you're doing I'm talking about those big
tech companies and other folks who might
not have your best interest at heart
that's why I use expressvpn and you
should too this way your data stays
yours it can't be sold and resold when I
use expressvpn you just click one button
transports you to another server and
also give you access to fun content that
might be available in another country
it's like you're a global traveler
without ever leaving your home get an
extra 3 months of expressvpn free by
going to expressvpn.com yangang that's e
p
sbn.com yangang for three extra months
free expressvpn.com
[Music]
yangang so this is a tech prediction
that blends in to some of the other
stuff we're talking about I think that
uh 2024 ends up becoming the AI cycle
where you have uh deep fake videos uh
and audios down the stretch over the
last several weeks uh that uh end up
causing a lot of confusion and turmoil
um you saw this by the way there there
was another country where like there's a
last minute deep fake and it might have
made the difference things with Estonia
so you're so you're going to see uh this
be the AI cycle all sorts of weird
shit's gonna come up in our social media
feeds over the last uh two three weeks
and that could be one of the defining
Elements by the way it's also going to
make it so it's uh it's easier for folks
to um argue that there was fraud or uh
something uh was rigged or stolen
because that there's going to be a lot
of AI generated confusion down the
stretch of the Fall so here's what the
political tactic is see can't do deep
fakes in a multi-state
primary too often because there is a
good and I'm happy for this there's a
healthy public backlash if you do it and
it's happened I think the santis did one
where it's it's not good and you have to
apologize and you have to say that was
wrong or I don't agree with that right
but when you're talking about late in
the game stuff or like win or take all
so it's the end of super Tuesday or the
national
election what will happen is some Savvy
political operative or company will
create a deep fake video and run ads on
it on TV or wherever it is um or deep
fake phone calls Etc that have their
opponent doing something awful something
that you know and you have this data
like it crosses a line that voters
really really don't like right it's a
it's it's something like U showing that
a republican is pro-choice instead of
pro-life like last minute right
something awful or something personal
attacks and it happens last minute so
you can't really respond it's right
before election day and then the
election happens and people either stay
home or vote a different way and then in
the aftermath you'll find out usually um
because it's going it has to go to
enough people for it to be public but
then the election happened right and so
that's what's GNA happen the question is
do people tune it out do they are we
used to this Etc but to your point it's
the first one it's the first time we're
doing this right so you have some you'll
have folks my mom's age and others that
are the demographic voters and they're
seeing something that looks and feels
very real what are they going to do I
don't know it doesn't look great and so
I agree with you it's a powerful
political AI prediction my prediction on
AI is that we have an
AI it's my similar prediction I had web
3 and maybe I'll be wrong again but uh
AI gets Mass adopted in some version I
think it's going to be a personal
assistant I think that's the first one
where like what hey Siri is um where
Siri is where it's hey book me an
appointment write this email
get me a reso I think it gets really
good there um I could be wrong but
that's no I I I think that's a good
prediction uh I just met with an
entrepreneur who's working on an AI
therapy bot um which by way I think
there's a lot of potential for there's
angles what's crazy Andrew is when we
were running you were talking about um
non-repetitive cognitive work you're
like cognitive or repetitive and so
non-repetitive cognitive work was the
ones that we thought would be quote
unquote safe but now you're seeing like
design and musicians and AI really
kicking ass in some of those areas as
opposed
to it sucks at like it sucks at writing
somewhat uh it can do basic writing but
it s but like there's there's certain
Lanes where I thought creatives would
stay strong and like anything repetitive
would would get rocked and it's not as
clear-cut yeah yeah the the repetitive
non-repetitive stuff I mean so
repetitive you think it's rules-based
like a accounting bookkeeping um the the
tough truth is that a lot of quote
unquote creative work also uh is kind of
repetitive and like follows rules you
just don't really you know uh uh know
them as uh clearly a but AI can produce
art there's AI logo gener generator that
I've used and it's objectively good and
here's the other thing it does like the
basic work it gives me a hundred
Concepts a thousand Concepts and then I
can take that to massage it right it's
the same like I tell people it's great
at naming things where hey name this
thing and they'll give you five 10
suggestions and then you might not
choose any of them but you you're going
to end up springboarding off of one of
the suggestions uh to the one you want
you get an infinite brainstorm mental
steps you know what I mean like think
about when you're trying to name
something you like Google synonyms Etc
it just give me 20 names for a health
care policy whatever you want to do
right for a new company that does X it's
first of all it's very exciting and very
and everybody knows this um and I think
it's why I like listening to you I still
listen to your podcast because
you you understand the sorry man I mean
that's hysterical sorry yeah I listen
yeah um I like I don't list everything
it's tough sometimes but I I try to do
as many as can but you like the the
economy Humanity political tripod of how
AI is going to affect that's the type of
like leadership we need and that's the
type of like foresight we need
um and very few people actually do it um
and if they do it somewhat well they'll
never touch politics it's like if you
listen to the all-in guys I love them
they talk about politics they never run
like they'll just donate you know raise
money it's good fun and uh it's been fun
getting behind Dean in part because it
makes me appreciate uh how clear ey and
independent we can be um and in part
because of folks who tune into the
podcast or whatnot I'm not dependent on
the Democratic machine for anything in
the way that just about everyone over
there in uh both politics uh and media
are um uh and so being able to call out
things like hey guys Joe Biden's old and
unpopular there's a dumb idea and then
look around and and know that other
people are thinking the same thing and
are unable to say it uh I mean it's the
same thing when I was runting for
president on Ubi it's like hey guys
we're going to automate the [__] out of
a lot of things and then a lot of people
were like oh yeah that's totally
happening but but there but there was no
incentive for anyone to say it and the
great thing about you and me Zach is we
can do what we know is right and there
are enough people that still look at us
and support us and say okay those guys
are trying to do something good let me
at least check it out let me see what
they're up to let me see if I agree
right now the great hope for this
country is in my opinion the dean
Phillips campaign to give us a choice to
move on from Joe Biden you are grinding
on that every single day uh to close out
this convo what are you seeing on the
horizon for the campaign for Dean
Phillips for the primary someday maybe
at some point I'll maybe do a little
more inside baseball but the reality is
no one's paying attention to this race
which means no one's paying attention to
Dean Phillips or really Joe Biden except
you've probably heard polls suck which
is true are yeah yeah they're terrible
not good um the goal is New Hampshire
I'm GNA New Hampshire is New Hampshire
on January 23rd Let's Go janary 23 there
and that should be a a moment um and
it's funny I've talked to to Dean about
this where he talks about um when he
said he created tente
gelato he there were two big ice cream
players and what happens when you have a
essentially two monopolies where it's
like one or the other it's it becomes a
race to the bottom um and so tent was
able to find a healthy middle um at a
you know high quality at a reasonable
price um and kind of stand out in that
world and that's essentially what he's
doing in politics right now where we
have two parties that are monopolies
right they are you're either on the team
you're off and if you're off you're
you're toxic um and people are saying
things privately that they won't say
publicly which is insane so he's you
know trying to offer an alternative and
so my my vision is it's got to be real
you know got to be real it's got to be
people need to feel like this has a real
shot look he's going to be on the bout
in more than 40 States probably more
than 45 States that's enough to win we
got to wake the country up we got to we
are and this is stuff as a country we're
complacent right now we are like we hate
the out I mean I'll say it like right
now people are burnt out jaded negative
checked out uh you know um so it's hard
to shake them and be like yo we really
can do better than this like we can want
more we can make changes we can still
have new leaders that care about us that
will put us ahead of their own you know
Ambitions that we are their Ambitions I
mean you know we we still need these
things um but but like and in many ways
what's funny Zach is like you you and I
ran this campaign in 2020 and I think a
lot of people who followed us came away
very very deeply disillusioned with the
nature of the machine they were like oh
my gosh like these guys don't play it
straight at
all you know what I mean and then this
cycle it's even worse where they're like
oh my gosh this time they're not even
pretending um but it it's it's the but
it's the same um freaking challenges to
overcome you know like it still has to
be we activate people this time we get
him to back Dean vote for Dean on
January 23rd in New Hampshire and then
it's game on where everyone looks up and
says wait a minute we don't need to just
accept that it's gonna be Joe um who's
this Dean fellow and then they'll check
him out uh they'll find he's a great
human being with a heart of gold uh he's
just a really really good genuine person
person who wants to do right by us the
fact that you're fighting to make it
happen uh makes me proud of you um and
uh you know I'm doing everything I can
to help too I hope people listening to
this will will do the
same this podcast is sponsored by Helix
sleep it's a pretty short list of things
you can do that are going to make you
happier healthier more energetic more
productive every single day you know
what's on that list getting the right
freaking mattress and what's the right
mattress for you if you go to Helix
sleep you take their personalized sleep
quiz and they will send you one of 20
unique mattresses made for you and you
alone well not you and you alone like 5%
of people do the math for 100 night free
trial you can sleep on this thing for
three months it will keep you cool don't
just take my word for it my kids seek
out this mattress in the house it's the
number one rated mattress picked by GQ
and Wired Magazine this mattress will
actually make you you happier healthier
and more productive Helix is offering
20% off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com yangang this is their
best offer yet and it won't last long
with Helix better sleep starts
[Music]
now so big predictions for 2024 drum
roll we have the Democratic party moves
on from Joe Biden third parties get
double digits in the election the mild
recession happens AI goes mainstream in
your life AI ends up screwing up
politics down the stretch in November
and we're going to close with hey go
check out
d124.org
at the end of 24 so go ahead Zach so I
predicted the bills to win the Super
Bowl last year and then
um dear Hamlin almost essentially
technically died on the field and it
kind of rocked our team in a way I
wasn't ready for um so I'm not going to
predict the bills as though I think we
might get hot I I think the
Ravens Ravens ners Ravens take it this
year I think they're the best team we'll
see but I mean look I'm rooting for the
bills I think we are the best team we
play well but we've been a little
streaky this year uh what do you think
they on to run you know that they could
be like get hot baby don't let us get
hot don't let them get hot yeah I think
the bills make the plow and make some
noise personally um the the matchup that
jumped to mind for me is the Ravens ners
I think i' I'd take the Niners that they
seem like they they've got that Mojo
this year though I I do really like
Lamar Jackson and the Ravens and I i'
enjoy lar so fun to watch um he's um and
so and then Travis and Taylor so I heard
a rumor everybody hears rumors just
Taylor S just every gossip um but it was
someone told me that um Carly someone
Carly had told me she'd been reading
some blogs Etc that there was there's a
fan theory that they've been dating for
a while and that the friendship bracelet
that he brought up on his podcast and
them meeting was like a very
well-calculated roll out um to get the
deserved PR around it which honestly
would make sense because it seemed like
it accelerated so quickly like she's
with the family like it was like two
weeks in she's like hanging with the mom
and like that sort of thing um so I'm
GNA say they're together for I think
they have a really I don't wish ill I
hope I hope they're actually in love my
gut says it's going to be a very public
breakup and we're going to get a really
good album out of it maybe that's
selfish and but I hope Taylor finds love
and I think last thing I'll say if
Taylor gets married and has babies it
will be one of the best baby booms in
this country that's probably my last
prediction if that happens we're going
to have a baby boom in the United States
and that'll be good
yeah whatever she names the baby will be
the most popular baby name that year I
do think Taylor Swift could run for
president and do very very well and win
I mean I publicly said like Taylor
because you know you attend um an ARS
tour and you see that that that uh he's
clearly rational you know um yeah but
but also she's she's got the right
personal qualities in my opinion I mean
actually you know what that's what I say
I want I want to close this Andrew that
when I first before I took the job with
you I talked to three or four of people
who worked very closely with you from
Venture for America or other businesses
and I believe you're known by The
Company You Keep and all of those people
and I asked him for like I'm like [__]
on him to me I'm like give me his worst
give me this and they all um they swore
by you they loved you you know they
really did love you as humans um as a
human being and uh I had the same thing
with Dean was one of the things that
stood out to me was that his family and
his the people around him and his
staffers from Minnesota and folks have
known him for years really do love him
and I think the Press will say this and
Twitter will say that and blah blah blah
blah blah right but at the end of the
day like who really knows somebody is
the people they spend the most time with
that's how you generally can tell if
someone's a good human being um and I
believe in in my own experience too is
that Dean's a great human being and
Andrew Yang's a great human being and so
I think that's what we need to be asking
for and not splitting hairs over
policies like I don't know if we have
good human beings in our leadership uh
in this country right now so like we'll
leave you with when we ended in 2020
2016 there were times you probably get
really excited about a candate whether
it's Andrew or Bernie or someone and you
felt hope and uh then it goes away and
you feel sad and I do feel there's my
glimmer of hope right now uh and I'm
clinging to it you know what I mean de
Dean Phillips is a great human being he
gives me hope as well you give us hope
Zach people see in you the prince that
you are I'm so glad that my colleagues
lied about me uh to you th those uh
months ago nice work people they were
good man Joe guy shout out Joe guy his
name is Joseph R guy he's the man uh he
was an old roommate of mine that's how I
met Andrew technically uh because he was
working for vfa early on and he gave me
the whole SHP and he's like Andrew I
will take a bullet for Andrew Yang um oh
so nice Joe guy's a great
guy literally great Mr guy but you're
totally right if if the country knew
what they had in Dean Phil
uh he would win because for sure he he's
a genuine guy human he's a genuine about
you too if everybody can meet you if
everybody can meet Dean we'd win that's
but that's not the game the game is uh
one I gotta play in many ways Man the
game is trying to take who we are uh and
filtered through a machine and the
Machine wants to funh house me or Dean
it certainly you know enjoyed
occasionally fun house miring me yeah um
and so so then you have a couple of uh
ways of getting the word out but that
that is a challenge and I'm convinced
the machine is crumbling machine's still
quite strong and powerful and what
initiated my presidential campaign in
many ways when I was in DC saying hey
guys we're automating the jawe what are
we going to do and then one person said
[__] another person said [__]
another person said [__] and the
fourth person said Andrew you're in the
wrong town this is not a town of leaders
this is a town of followers we're not
going to do anything and the only way we
would do something is if you bring the
way of crashing down our heads and
people remember that from the campaign
great line still true today it's not a
town of leaders town of followers got to
bring the wave crashing down their heads
and this time the wave is going to start
on January 23rd in New Hampshire Zach
thank you for taking time out of the
busy campaign to spend some time with us
uh to continue the tradition of New
Year's predictions we're going to see
how many of them come true and in some
cases we're going to work like mad to
make them come true hell yeah man um
anyway those of you listen I love you I
love being on thanks for taking care of
Andrew I'm not here stay strong have a
wonderful happy holiday Happy New Year I
guess this is aing on New Year's right
so hope you had a happy holiday have a
happy New Year let's make 24 2024 our
best year yet let's do it 2024 let's go
thank you Zach see you out in the the
trail yes
sir